I feeling her okay I think it's
important for you to understand the
bigger picture yeah
you come with me please thank you
hopefully what I have planned will open
Kelly's eyes
[Music]
Kelly this is some of your guests I'd
like you to share your experiences what
do we start off with you frozen please
first impressions are important to me
and then the very first thing I had to
do is sign a cleaning waiver and it just
it makes the assumption that I'm not
going to be clean that assumption was it
was just a tough first impression yes
about the point
waivers are for bungee jumps how you
apparel that whole thing for me wasn't
to make you think that I didn't think
that you were clean it was I had someone
come in and throw a red wine all over
the Venetian plaster and I thought that
I should charge them for that every
other guest license of one guess that
it's not right you know you can't
penalize future business on the back of
one idiot it appears that there's no
flat into what the customers gonna
experience rinses the first thing and a
hot day you want to go into the pool and
we looked out to the pool and it's right
now it's the same way it's got a lot of
leaves and it's dirty so that maybe it's
not open but how can it not be open yes
another point flatten please we were in
the lounge for dinner and when you were
singing we couldn't have a conversation
it's just not appropriate for an upscale
intimate fine dining experience I feel
like you're very focused on the
performance but you're not really
focused on your guests very interesting
so anything that goes wrong with the
restaurant when you're singing you're
too busy singing and not caring about
your guests I would pay you 100 bucks
not to sing as long as you are focused
on your singing career and not on your
restaurant and hotel career my wife and
I won't be back
I don't agree I have quite a bit of
people that come here to hear music
guess feedback is critical it's about
turning that negativity into something
positive now I'd like to introduce you
to a very special lady Neelu Mohammed
she is the featured director and the
senior correspondent for Travel and
Leisure magazine needed and gives an
insight to your state please one of the
things that we look at is whether a
hotel has a sense of place whether it's
maximizing the value that that beautiful
setting that it's in have you mentioned
the pool that's one great example of a
moment where you have a potential great
asset here that is being underutilized
and it's kind of underwhelming there's a
reason why hotel schools exist so it's
not a hobby it's a business there is one
question I'd like to ask you all would
you come back to stay in this hotel
again please raise your hands no and
thank you to all your feedback has been
absolutely pivotal I appreciate it I was
sending a message that I didn't realize
I was sending and didn't want to send I
want people to come here I want them to
feel welcomed
are you starting to understand I am you
are sure worried about the wrong things
the biggest issue you have is
understanding who's number one
the guests have to be number one not
Kelly that's but that's the bottom line
if you can change that this place has
every chance of becoming a big success
do you change
be healthy I will help you Bob you've
got to start listening I can do it again
accent